The Joe Rogan Experience it brings us
back to haters they can get inspiration
from people you get juice yo shouts out
to that lady who's Emmy nominated that
hates me God bless God bless your soul
woman I had never thought about winning
an Emmy in my life but because you hated
on me when I got and she hates me for
the most ridiculous reason God bless her
so she hates me just because I'm not a
Democrat Dubois you know what I mean
like like I've had Democrats I like and
I push for them especially locally but
I'm sorry lady I can't be a dude boy and
God bless me to [__] around and get rich
I really I don't take money from any
politicians or political parties so if
you see me standing next to someone
because I really believe
um and if they don't convince me to
believe I'm not going to stand next to
him right she wanted me to stand next to
somebody I'm like you know sorry lady
I've had some conversations with us you
know I've just I've tried my best but
I'm not hating but it's just that ain't
my thing but this chick was just like
I'm gonna use my platform to and I'm
like you don't really have a platform
yeah but she in her bio she's an Emmy
nominated actress man winning at him he
sure felt good I just I blocked her but
I'm sure someone has told her but I'm
just like holding it I hope she sees the
picture like yeah thank God for your
hate lady because it made me care I went
to the I went to the ceremonies and
walked away with a trophy
congratulations yeah thank you and to
her there was a study that was done
recently about left-wing
authoritarianism and the way certain
people behave and that it's just it's
like a bunch of different psychological
conditions that are they're almost
indistinguishable yeah from like you
know like horrible narcissism
horrible uh like psychotic behavior like
see if you could find it what what their
conclusions were but at the fringes when
people what what happens is when you
have groups that are ideal ideological
groups whether it's the left or the
right yeah you're going to get people
that just join that group that are
absolutely insane yeah and if you don't
call it out then you have a giant
problem because people are going to
associate you with whatever the worst
aspects of your yeah like right-wing
proud boys
the experts somehow overlooked
authoritarians on the left many
psychologists wrongly assume that
coercive attitudes exist only among
conservatives of course it's a human
characteristic I did a speech for fire
for the organization fire and I miss
saying I'm sorry the brown shirts of
Italy but what I meant was the browsers
of Germany that as the as the left as
you accomplish more power politically
don't use it as a bludgeon in the same
way you've perceived it to be used
against you right that you you have to
you have to rule quote unquote in a in a
in a more fair and Equitable way you
can't let your fair in inequitable
thoughts become totalitarian yeah can't
give in to this crazy Instinct that we
all humans have to be tribal yes and I
am a Democrat I am a lifelong blue no
matter yes you can't that's right yes
both sides but we too I grew up I was
fortunate enough to grow up in a
household when my grandmother was SCLC
member had from Tuskegee had been apart
born in 1932 had been a part of civil
rights up my grandfather so my
grandmother grew up on a farm could go
to school they weren't wealthy but they
had food they had substance they had
education my grandfather grew up working
a sawmill at eight years old because his
father abandoned his family and he had
to feed his mothers and sisters so his
mentality was much more libertarian I
would say his fitmentality was if God
gave you an appetite and a mind to build
a fishing rod you should be able to
catch fish and my grandmother was like
you shouldn't complain about having to
buy a fishing license because the game
warden has to make sure things are legit
and somebody's to clean up the park so I
got a chance to see these wonderful
political arguments between two people
that loved each other you know my
grandmother college educated woman my
grandfather drove a truck and hauled
moonshine and gambled you know what I
mean he married this God-fearing woman
he never I never saw him walking to
church but they had these great debates
that showed me that there are no
absolutes that they're going to be some
things from each side that makes sense
yeah to run a good household and they
kind of they I watched them just do it
right you know what I'm saying and I
just I'm glad I saw that because I don't
feel married to any ideology that's
beautiful that's important shout out to
Betty and Willie God bless the dead man
yeah getting attached to ideologies is
always a bad idea particularly when you
do human beings have in America have two
choices yeah you have two choices yeah
the left and the right and people just
like they adhere they adhere to whatever
this side's doing because they want him
to win and then you have some weird
problematic figures like Trump who comes
along yeah and like the there's a lot of
never Trumper Republicans they don't
know what to do yeah but I say in this
crazy ass country pay attention to the
people who have no chance of winning
sometimes because they're gonna they're
gonna be some truths told like no matter
what you feel about Trump there was a
moment in that debate Chappelle talks
about it when Trump said of course these
loopholes exist they exist he was
talking to Hillary yeah like hell yeah
I'm gonna take advantage of the loophole
yeah because they also exist for the
people who've done that in your campaign
I was like yeah finally yeah a member of
the oligarchy class says yeah
[__] we're cheating yeah and I
was just like I was like that at that
point American should have said hard
reset yeah like they literally should
have said pre-iser had a hard reset
we're gonna we're gonna reform all this
[__] the money's gonna work different
none of us said a goddamn thing and you
know why because because we're all we're
all complacent in some confessions we're
all accompanied in this in this grand
scheme that's [__] us over and and
and if you don't have an educated
constituency or proletariat it's all
just going to counter reform so like
during this election people's like who
are you supporting I was like I don't
give a [__] nationally I give a [__] to
Cornell West is in the race because I'm
interested to see what he's going to say
Kennedy I'm interested just to hear you
know whatever crazy [__] people think
he's
um whoever else is running I'm just
interested because the two parties we
know we got but there are all these
little voices that pop up that little
grains of Truth they stand no chance of
winning in some cases but let me just
take a grain of what you're saying and
and that way I'll know what to take back
to the party that wins and say hey what
about this why do we have money for this
but we don't have money for this you
know like Sanders people told me like
Mike you're a business guy you like
money Sanders even said hey I think
you're going to be a billionaire I'm
gonna tax the [__] out of you too we
were laughing and joking backstage at
the Amazon worker strike that we were
both supporting but
my thing is I don't want to pay the
government more taxes but if I got to
pay more taxes let me pay
with the guys playing who's going to
educate kids and trades and scholarships
for free because that way I'm making a
20-year investment so my 16 year old
daughter when she's 36 has a much better
country full of educated Kids versus
yeah I bought a lot I bought more
missiles you know what I'm saying yes
yes yeah that's possible but that's not
possible but if you don't put them in
now I am a millionaire I'm gonna do my
best to protect my [__] money yeah
because I wasn't born a millionaire you
know I mean I was born just a working
cash black kid named Michael yeah you
know what I mean and Michael had to
Michael never liked working at Six Flags
or AutoZone or UPS so once Michael
[__] around to figure out how to sing
and dance and makes money Michael wants
to save more of his money than spend you
know